il ya les effets d'annoncé puis la
réalité nous venons nous sommes dans le
coeur a le plein centre de kiev d'où
vous viennent longtemps d'une explosion
qui est un bombardement en direction et
comme depuis plusieurs jours du norway
c'est à dire les faubourgs de kiev la
ville satellitaire de ir pin donc sur le
terrain évidemment les annonces de
moscou et laisse sceptique pour le moins
les salles et sentent dizaines de
milliers de familles que l'on voit
échapper de seville satellitaire le
temps en plus ce matin et comme vous
pouvez certainement le constater il se
met à neiger il fait extrêmement froid
nous avons passé plusieurs une demi
journée hier dans les faubourgs de ir
pin donc qui est où les combats font
rage c'est en fait le nouveau front pour
l'en l'accès au nord-ouest à kiev où il
ya ce rôle au que le rouleau compresseur
de l'armée russe qui approche de manière
presque implacable et inexorable donc
imaginer ce matin ses flots de famille
qui continue d'essayer de rentrer dans
kiev avec ces conditions météorologiques
extrêmement difficiles et c'est effet
d'annonce vous le disais des couloirs
humanitaires de cessez-le-feu
annoncé par moscou auquel franchement
personne ne croit ici et les stratèges
militaires ukrainien ne s'y trompe pas
puisqu'il ya énormément de cynisme je
dirais de la part de moscou de proposer
un couloir humanitaire pour évacuer des
civils non pas vers la pologne non pas
vers la hongrie n'ont pas vers le centre
de l'ukraine mais vers la biélorussie et
la russie alors évidemment il est moscou
s'est vu opposer une fin de non-recevoir
qu'on pourra bien comprendre mais c'est
aussi ça la guerre psychologique le
finisse mme de l'armée russe c'est à
dire de d'affaiblir les populations
civiles en leur promettant des
cessez-le-feu alors qu'il ya des
bombardements il y a déjà eu deux
cessez-le-feu depuis le début de
l'invasion qui n'ont tenu que quelques
heures l'armée russe laisse sortir les
civils et leur tire dessus en même temps
c'est ça la réalité que l'on voit ici
sur le terrain à à kiev et également
pour finir comment demander à une
population qui est en train de se
mobiliser toute entière et on le voit
c'est très très clair ici pour résister
à cette offensive russe pourquoi ne lui
proposait finalement que de fuir pour
beaucoup je dirais pour la majorité
des habitants de kef ici c'est
totalement inacceptable